yo it's your boy Roy Woods make sure you
check me out on the bootle Kev podcast
you already
know yo man bootleg Kev podcast special
guest he uh is on tour right now uh
doing his thing man Roy Woods is in the
building yes sir yes sir what's good my
brother welcome man uh how's it feel to
get on the road and sing these new songs
from amazing bro this album that
everybody was waiting for for so long
I've been I've been waiting to sing
these songs for so long you know so yeah
it feels good like me and the team me
man there we go to rehearsals all the
time and we're like you know been doing
a lot of um the older songs from Co
because of Co and everything right right
so like but I have the new songs and new
songs are building so I'm like damn I
want to perform these songs but so now
that I get to and I've seen the reaction
and what the fans like like I'm just
like oh right wow you guys really like
the new you know what I'm saying this
new [__] so yeah it feels amazing dog
how many dates in are you man uh we're
halfway in yeah we're halfway in the
tour yeah so now we just got to do with
the East Coast yeah have you you haven't
done home yet no home is the last show
December 13th yeah that's going to be
insane y yeah yeah for sure shout out to
uh for people who don't know like what
was your main reason for taking so long
to drop an album cuz it was what 5year
Hiatus or something like that yeah like
something like that yeah um so like
right after the right after I came off
to Dr and 3 Migos tour
like I went on like a little I want I
needed to take a break cuz Lots was
going on like I just I found out my
friend died after I went on vacation and
my management situation was crazy at
that time I had a different manager than
you see right now stuff I have two
managers always had two managers and
he's always been around they' both
always been around but my brother Banks
here I I brought him in cuz I needed a
restructure but I didn't bring him in
until we're already a year into Co right
and he was bringing plays and I was like
oh why you bring a lot of players out we
eating right now so I was like you know
what it just made me see where I what I
should do with my team so I was like you
know let me do that but it was I just I
really wanted to when to take a year off
and then Co made me you know CO's a
[__] yeah so that that just
ruined everything you know I was trying
to drop the album and a lot of push back
was that the tour where Drake was
running around on the basketball court
yeah that was the one yeah that was the
one yeah yeah yeah just I was like the
cardio Drake had on that tour had to be
crazy it was just like a giant
basketball court size stage screen thing
and you have people like come and shoot
and and they want like a prize or prize
money or something I can't remember how
much but it was a lot I remember what
was that tour like it was amazing it was
crazy I was it was crazy cuz I was
depressed the whole tour though you know
why were you like what was the industry
and me was like it was just clashing you
know like I'm like I was trying to like
almost fit in instead of trying to just
be myself and I was kind of just going
through like a whole bunch of phases
where I was like okay so who am I
supposed to be right and yeah I was just
lost I was lost that whole tour was that
the first culture album that Migos were
toning was that culture two no yeah it
was culture 2 Dam yeah that's when all
the the crazy hits they were performing
they had some [__] yeah that album was
insane what was it like uh like
obviously for people who don't know
takeoff did you have a relationship with
him obviously being on the road you know
what I never really spoke to a lot of
the Migos I I SP I really only met quo
okay right but um me and myself take off
knew of me yeah you know rest in peace
take cuz you were opening the tour right
yeah I was opening the tour um I
remember I spoke to one of his artists
at the time we were supposed to do a
feature and then we it was just we like
some on Instagram in the DMS or some
[__] she was just so love you know so
you know we knew of each other you know
and he knew of me but we never really
spoke but it was always like a when you
know when you show me love on Grandma
was like oh okay salute you know like
it's it's myad love what's been your
favorite city so far on the tour uh this
La show was actually like la la was
insane like good cities um we were at
the novo oh noo a VI yeah the novo was
good I did it last tour too so great
venue yeah man it was good it was really
good really good amazing turn I was
going to ask you uh for you man like is
it is it you know when you're signed to
OVO there's a certain level of prestige
that comes with that for you is there
ever like what are the negatives about
that obviously then all the random Drake
questions you probably get but is there
any cuz we always think like oh if
someone's like Drake co-signs you
there's a lot of great that comes with
it but is there a gift in a curse of
that that like you like I mean you could
say because well he is the biggest
artist in the world like in a sense you
know so not even in a sense so like you
know what comes with like trying to it's
him or the
weekend I would it's a I feel like it's
always been a battle but but it's one of
them too they're both from your city no
for sure yeah I mean I feel like one
week and the second you know what I'm
saying like it's like I feel like it's
always been like right there but um I
mean also Hey Taylor
Swift Taylor Taylor Swift bro that [__]
is selling out all kind of [__]
football stadium she she's crazy she's
on a whole different League though she's
doing movie [__] yeah number one
movie in the different numbers yeah I
don't know yeah she doing different
numbers I don't get the Taylor thing God
bless her I don't know I don't know
single song bro do you like her music I
mean I never really listen to it too
much but you know cuz it never was but I
know the song I love her songs are they
slapping Taylor Swift in Canada uh yeah
of course like crazy they are they love
it yeah they love Taylor Swift uh but
you were saying is there what is the
gift and the curse for the OVO co- yeah
um I mean it it's I feel like when you
get signed to like a big artist it's
always different compared to being
signed on the label there's a lot that
you have to fight through but I mean I
found out I find that there was a lot of
benefits with me being on the label you
know just and me being the artist that I
am I'm already so different so then
already being on the label that now
being different and people naturally
like my you know sound me being
different who I am it I feel like it
just worked in my favor so there was I
never always yeah there's always
negatives but I always look past it and
focus on those positives and just what
are the the negatives I mean it was
always just trying to get around C maybe
certain barriers you know but at the end
of the day I always find a way to get
around you know if I can't go that way
I'm going to go this way you know find
my way do you uh like like how's like
the relationship with everybody on the
label cuz there's obviously you m
Jordan's great [__] fire yeah man
every everybody's good Smiley's amazing
yeah dog we're all we're all family man
you know what I'm say smile's the
funniest guy everybody we all love
Smiley man dude he came on the show and
freestyled and it was like Smiley's
freestyle on our show like I it was very
interesting but I just me and him still
sing it every like for real once every
few days we're like dropping lines from
his free he's like it's
Cody that's my dog oh I love Smiley man
and the whole what is the toron like
give me some Toronto slang that we could
use if we ever go to to Toronto what is
like cuz y'all be saying some [__] I
don't understand what the [__] means
you know mandm
mm that's a okay that's a basic one
mandm is just like the guys you know oh
like man and them no no just man them
like the man's them like the man's them
you know like I'm with the man them yeah
see it there yeah yeah there we go yeah
yeah yeah there we go yeah you know and
you know things that's that's that's a
that's a b that a Toronto thing is that
a Toronto are you guys claiming Tings no
I mean it's it's it's not just a Toronto
thing like I got a Ting over here even
the Toronto lingo is not even just a
Toronto thing you know it's really it's
like a it's really a yti thing like a
Jamaican Caribbean influence and then UK
also has very similar thing even New
York my [__] New York has very similar
thing no New York got some other [__]
bro what
up yeah but I mean okay for I've seen
something the other day Instagram they
like they they saying it's brick outside
we say it's brick outside too Tonto cold
exactly yeah yeah we say brick for cold
yeah but it's a we say the same [__]
certain things is the same you know we
say fam we say fam a lot I think a lot
of people seem to think that like
Toronto is like a really sweet place but
then you know recently people have gone
there and gotten robbed yeah yeah it's
not it's not sweet as everybody very
active from what I hear in certain areas
it's it's always been the whole city is
yeah it can get popping anywhere really
doesn't matter who you are too yeah yeah
it gets popping is it like is there a
protocol if you go to Toronto do do you
have to check in no man or you it's not
like that bad it's not like Detroit no
no no no I listen I don't know about all
that if you go to Detroit you got to
check in with trick trick yeah see I
don't hey I don't know man you know back
in the the culture is different now the
culture is different compared to how it
used to be you know in the streets so
yeah how we feeling about uh the Raptors
you feeling good about the uh Scotty
Barnes is balling you you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you know what I haven't
even been paying attention to no sports
like not even football this year for
some reason you I know you you play
football yeah yeah I coach now a little
bit too you know what I'm saying but
like but I used to I used to play are we
talking soccer or football no American
football okay I got to ask cuz you're
from a different country and I know in
everywhere else football fo too we got
we got a leave watches the CFL I watch
it man I'm Canadian you know Canadians
we watch it do they have the NFL on in
Canada of course we do yeah we got the
NFL yeah I don't know we got we got we
watch we got everything we got
everything so you play football what
like tackle football yeah yeah tackle
football but in in Canada we don't have
four downs we have three Downs it's
weird really yeah and our football is
like bigger way it's like it's
difference you have a bigger ball yeah a
bigger football field as well it's like
120 yards yeah it's crazy the end Zone's
huge man it's like back in the day 1950
stle football wait is that how the CFL
is yeah yeah go search up type in CFL
highlights whatever you'll see how big
the field giant ball yeah it's big bro
so you're like you have pads on and a
helmet and Sh everything yeah number 80
yeah are you a wide receiver yeah I was
a wide receiver and a a safety and a
punter but mainly receiver yeah punting
kicking yeah punting catching and
defending and yeah yeah I'm the I'm the
the Deep help what got you into football
my dad your dad the football guy yeah
when he moved to Guyana from Guyana to
Canada uh the first um football game he
ever seen was the Chicago Bears I think
it was when the year that won the Super
Bowl the 85 Bears yeah and you know he
just fell in love with the Bears so he's
a Bears fan he's a bear yeah he's a
Bears fan I'm a Steelers fan yeah so
you're a Steelers fan yeah I'm a
Steelers fan for what gravitated you
towards the Steelers I don't know I used
to play I used to play Madden all the
time and I used to watch their game
sometimes and I was just like y I just
love the way they play football no no
this is back Jerome Bettis and Cordell
storeart Cordell was a beast yeah when
Plaxico was on the team bur Ward
yeah I mean yeah that happened Paul yeah
Troy but Troy wasn't on the team them
times then so then I remember when I
watched the 05 06 Super Bowl when they
play Seahawks that I was like holy [__]
there was a whole new team right but it
was the last game for Bettis I watched
that and I was like oh my God this is
just hey want to shout out to our good
Folks at Imperial man our newest
partners right here on the bootleg Kev
podcast man right now they're getting
you hooked up with free 2 G pre-rolls
yes now let me tell you about Imperial
man Imperial they've been doing this
they ain't new to this they're True to
this they got 16 years in the west coast
cannabis space and now Imperial
extraction is bursting onto the hemp
scene now if y'all don't know that means
you can get Imperial extraction
delivered right to your
door wherever you are in the United
States yes that's right now this is
what's going on now Imperial extraction
they got so much [__] I'm telling you
man these pods have been what I've been
smoking on man I love the white Berry
runs you get you your battery you get
you your pod and you're Vaped up but
what's really dope is right now you can
get a free free 2 G THC a diamond
infused pre-roll with any order yes
that's right that pre-roll comes with
1.5 grams of top shell flour
I mean look man that thing is huge it's
got the premium glass tip it's got the
diamonds if y'all don't know what the
diamonds is it's the THC infused thca
diamonds um look it's about that luxury
smoke all right an imperial that's what
they provide and you can get a free 2 G
pre-roll right now it's free and it's
going to get delivered right I don't
care where you're watching this I don't
care if uh weed is legal uh illegal
whatever this is where at it's going to
get delivered right to your door all
right that's right get a free 2 G thca
Diamond infused pre-roll right to your
door when you go to the website Imperial
extraction. go to Imperial extraction.
comom load up on some goodies all right
load up on some of this la king Kush
some of this cereal milk some of this
tropical
punch use the promo code bootleg that's
the key use that promo code bootleg if
you use that promo code you're going to
get a free pre-roll delivered to your
door come on man who don't love free
weed I love free weed so what are we
doing one more time Imperial extraction.
use the promo code bootleg at checkout
free pre-roll getting delivered to you
ASAP you already know man it's
Thanksgiving week right here we got a
shout out to my bookie man this is an
exclusive offer only happening this week
y'all my bookie if y'all don't know I be
hitting these super teasers on my bookie
every Sunday I put together four picks
put them on a super teaser plus 13
I've been banging them out every week
all right if you've been following me on
Instagram you know but listen right now
we have a special offer that's only this
week and it's very exclusive to the
bootle C podcast you're going to get a
110% deposit match up to $11,000 I want
y'all to know what that means if you put
in 1,000 bucks they're going to match
that $1,000 with $ 110% deposit match
that means they're going to give you
1,00 bucks in free money to gamble with
my bookie . a you're only going to get
that if you use the promo code bootleg
that's right use that promo code bootleg
there's
110% deposit match uh up to 1,000 bucks
that means you're going to get $1,100
back if you deposit $1,000 now this is
only happening until this Sunday coming
up the 26 all right then it's a wrap 110
this is unheard of by the way this is
[__] insane 110% deposit bonus if you
want to gamble on Sports if you want to
hit the real Casino they got they got
blackjack let all that NFL on turkey day
uh NFL on on Sunday NBA Black Friday
look all of it you got to sign up with
that promo code
bootle right now at
mybookie.ag put in that first deposit
now look the minimum deposit to get this
bonus is 50 bucks anything over50
dollars they're going to um match 110%
of mybookie.ag use that promo code take
advantage of just this week what the
[__] are we doing go do it it was
different for me when I was a kid so
have you been game and you know I never
been to a Steelers game I actually want
to do that this tour I want to do that
yeah I want to go I want to go yeah I
want to catch one man see Kenny picking
and GP and these guys man yeah hey man I
want I don't know how you guys are six
and three it's the biggest mystery to me
you guys are the luckiest team ever cuz
you guys don't have much talent on try
we're trying no we have talent Harris
somehow washed in his third year no it's
not he's not washed Jaylen Warren is way
better than Naj Harris oh my God see the
outside criticism is crazy jayen Warren
just had 110 yards on I na had like 83 I
seen how much carries it was simil na
Harris I don't know how he just fell
off system I feel like the system that
they're trying to um play in right now
like with Matt Canada it's too all over
the place they don't have a ident as
they said an identity right now you know
are they are you a pass are you a pass
team are you do you pass deep are you
just trying to run first like what do
you guys doing like nobody knows over
there so you believe in Kenny picket
yeah he has talent I've seen you believe
like that's your quarterback listen I
believe he can definitely take us
somewhere yes if he has Yes Man the guy
when I seen him in his rookie when I
seen him in his rookie season and I seen
him making progression this is the
conference that has Joe burrow Allen
Patrick Mahomes Justin Herbert can he
pick it I feel like once he gets [__]
bum no he's not man he is a homeless man
no my God you're the hate is crazy Kenny
picket is nor man the man was making
progressions as a Young quarterback that
was like that's that's insane you just
need to there's so many good good things
I seen making right decisions in his
rookie year like when he really started
getting the groove I said yo there's a
lot of potential that they can work on
right here you know what I'm saying but
they have no idea very young offensive
line very everybody's so young on that
on that offense Kenny picket and Mitch
Tris are not that far apart no they are
far apart definitely I feel like they're
far apart come on I feel like you got to
give Kenny I feel like no some some more
time yeah little Chad one more year
especially with the different OC and
then I'll make my assumption on how you
know what I'm saying I going to go ter
I feel like I feel like they you rather
have Jos
Doss is playing really nice exactly you
could you could but but he mind you he
was on the Steelers he was and you guys
should have you had he was on the
Steelers then he went to the Browns then
he went to my Cardinals then we traded
to the Vikings the Vikings and he's
balling right now crazy I believe in
Kenny though I believe in Kenny you're
you're a sweet guy cuz you're famous and
you know you might meet him one day no I
really believe in Kenny man I watched gu
play man no I'm not Kenny Kenny pick it
I believe in you I follow bro I like
I like what I see man I believe he's
going to yeah man I feel like once he
gets in a right situation once he gets
like you know once they F their identity
on offense I feel like we can see
something something really happen dog
you see fourth quarter Kenny we all you
see him in the fourth quarter the man's
going crazy like he's Brady over there
right you see it come on you don't
you're telling me you're not seeing the
fourth quarter highlights bro you guys
have gotten lucky all season long
there's actually a stat cuz I gamble and
there's like a way they figure out like
the luckiest teams and the over the last
three years the Pittsburgh Steelers have
the the the most they're the most lucky
team of football because of how close
their wins are yeah yeah yeah winning by
very close they barely just won 1.3
points yeah we're winning by those even
with Ben though that's what was going on
well cuz Ben was like a corpse yeah but
I mean I feel like it's really just for
like the last five years of Ben's career
he was like the Joe Biden the
quarterbacks like just waiting for him
to like fall break everybody was but he
was still slinging in he wasn't the same
old Ben but he was still slinging it
shout out to the Steelers who would have
thought huh yeah man you guys beat my
I'm a cardinal f you guys beat us in the
Super Bowl look at that and you have so
much to say [__] the Steelers man I hate
the [__] Steelers I can tell no
wonder no wonder no wonder this energy
is coming so heavy from the side of the
room right now you think it is a bum
he's not man you guys going to drop
somebody man no I feel like he can do
amazing things you just got to give him
some patience get the right offensive
system going on and we'll figure it out
trust me man trust me watch watch watch
you got to go to a game I can't believe
I got through I really got have you been
a football game yes yes yes I've been to
yeah NFL game my first one was the
Chargers against Patriots last last yeah
yeah yeah here oh yeah lost against the
Patriots depressing
huh I like Herbert man I like no they're
great but the fact that they put this
team in the middle of La that no one in
La gives a [__] about I don't know I
don't know why they did that when they
were from San Diego kep in San Diego San
Diego loved them any Chargers the Rams
here too I was very confused because the
Rams is already been here from how many
years charers games are just away games
for them I mean I I I when you win there
was tons of Patriots fans there was so
much Patriots fans I was very surprised
I couldn't believe but I it was a great
it was a great game though you know the
Chargers I feel like they're a team that
just always comes up short you never
it's CU their coach is a [__] idiot
but I mean it's been happening since
like what oh the ' 80s actually yeah
since Thomason and all that but I mean
before Thom Fels we're talking D Fels
Kell winow times they're cursed I don't
know why they're amazing offense amazing
players so many stars but they just
can't finish game yeah that's true it is
rough they who they just lose to oh the
Lions yeah that was a good game just
lost the LI yeah I didn't even know yeah
yeah see yeah it was a close game too
yeah like three points or something so
um how how long obviously you're going
to get off tour soon about halfway
through how uh how soon are you going to
go back in and make make the next album
I'm already I'm already I'm already
working on it yeah I'm already working
on it I'm already working on it I'm
working a lot of music right now was it
when's it early next year yeah yeah I
want to get that out first quarter so
you're not going to make everybody wait
half a decade Kevin I'm not playing with
him I'm not playing with him Kevin I was
going to say like like uh for you like
cuz you know a span of 5 years people
come and go right like music changes
yeah Tik Tok probably wasn't popping
like that in 2018 2019 it really wasn't
it just started actually yeah so it's
like the whole music industry kind of
changes for you like uh you know how do
you like kind of still make people give
a [__] uh cuz once you go away so long
man fans move on they find new people
like but obviously you're still doing
your thing the tour is going crazy but
like me it's like hard to like be gone
for 5 years per se I mean you were
dropping some [__] but like and like
still make people care like yeah I mean
it was I was hard cuz I I was even
trying to figure it out and I feel like
it's just me being naturally honest and
myself yeah I can't do no gimmicky
[__] and feel like that's kind of
you know what I'm saying I'm just not
that person or that artist never been so
I'm just honest and that has been it's
been door opening it's been eye opening
it's been you know what I'm saying cuz
they now get to I'm letting him in I've
been so reserved I'm so closed off so I
feel like cuz when I was telling you
about you know the industry and
everything I feel like it just made me
just go into my own little bubble you
know so I didn't let my even my fans in
that bubble so now that I'm letting them
in I feel like that's what I feel like
that's the only thing that they've been
missing really from me besides me
obviously dropping music right so that
connection just rebuilding that
connection you know what's what was
there anything that happened that made
you kind of like uh resent the music
industry at all um yeah the lack there I
feel like there some it was so fake I
realized man I learned how fake it
really was dog and the lack of love the
lack of you know like that's why like
you know when I like when I lose certain
people in this industry that was that
showed me genuine love like that hits
because it's like [__] like I don't
really talk to a lot of people out here
hey what up y'all we got to stop the
interview tell you about our good Folks
at King pom that's right let me tell you
about King pom man it's all we smoking
over here but I love about King pom
turpion infused flavor in each one of
these These are the Margarita now this
is kind of the wave I've been on
recently these Margarita ones are
[__] fire no tobacco no nicotine
straight raw organic fresh leaves um and
what's dope is they got the tip you
squeeze the tip you hit one of these
boys and you just get hit with that
flavor man you get hit with that flavor
no matter how big or small the Palm is
you know what I'm saying this is what's
dope too uh King pom if y'all don't know
man they're one of the leading Brands
when it comes to this real like organic
smoke light that's why I like them I
like to smoke clean nothing smokes
cleaner than a king pal so if you're in
your hood you're in your neighborhood
you're in your [__] City your
area wherever you're at go to your local
liquor store they're going to have King
poms all right so pick them up there you
could also go to 7-Eleven or this is
what I suggest you do right
now come on shout out to the king Pals
man go to the website King pom.com if
you go to King pom.com you use the promo
code bootleg
this is what we're doing 50% off
whatever you order they got so much at
King pom.com not only do they
got the
leaves not only do they got the
Grinders not only do they got the gas
trays they got them all the cones
50% off all the smoking accessories all
the leaves you need all the flavors 50%
off King pom.com promo code bootleg also
speaking of [__] you're going to get
some money off of our family our dogs
our our listen I'm going to uh Tampa to
go DJ for these guys holiday party odd
Soxs baby the holidays are here now is
the time to go to oddsocks official.com
and use that promo code bootleg all
right use it right now and guess what
you're going to get 20% off at checkout
now the dope thing about oddsocks they
got all the crazy licenses they just
locked down Coca-Cola recently yeah look
at those they just locked down Hasbro so
they got Power Rangers
Transformers all that I mean look they
got cheit bro you know what I'm saying
they got Hershey's chocolate bro they
got wwee they got Breaking Bad they got
Top Ramen they got the drawers they got
the socks they got the slippers they got
the Hat they got the belt whatever you
need odd Sox official.com load up for
the holidays gift odd Sox to your loved
ones whatever they're into there's an
odd Sox for it oddsock official.com use
the promo code bootleg when you check
out save 20% off let's get back to the
interview shout out to the homies over
at Blue Chu man that's right blue Chu
everybody always ask me does blue Chu
work well you don't take my word for it
try it for free for a month by using
that promo code bootleg right now blueo
has the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Calis uh it's all wrapped up
into a blue chewable form delivered
right to your doorstep in discret
packaging no doctor's
appointments uh are needed all right you
don't have to to go into the doctor
everything's online go to blue.com all
right sign up with that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free if
your dick ain't [__] it's time to get
a [__] again you know what I mean
you're dealing with little erectile
dysfunction maybe a little anxiety at
work maybe you're stressed out maybe
you're just married to someone you're
tired of [__] let's be honest
sometimes you need a little extra you
know a little extra some some to get you
over the Finish Line get that blue chew
baby
blue Chu try the first month for free
they're going to give it to you for free
a month supply for free go to blu.com
use the promo code bootleg right now
thank me later let's get back to the
interview yeah people are very strange
they're very finicky in the music
industry yeah I've noticed that's what I
learned they'll be swinging on your dick
and then like nine months later they're
they're they're like wait what you want
to answer your call you again yeah it's
crazy I see there's just so much clout
chasing especially at that time you know
that's when clout was so used a lot of
clout chasing was going on and I'm just
like like y I'm not into this clout [__]
like I'm just a are you are you staying
in La no no I'm still back I'm still
home in Toronto I was living in LA right
before Co and then K has said you know
what I got free healthcare my family's
there let me just go over and take
advantage of it how's the free
healthcare work you just uh you just go
in yeah you got to get a health card
once you get the health card then yeah
free healthcare so like certain things
you got to pay for but but like what
what what's free everything but I mean
going to see the doctor is free um let's
say you got to get uh you blow out your
ACL playing football yeah I I don't I
mean I know everything everything's
everything yeah I'm pretty sure it's
free yeah everything's free surgery
should be free CRA yeah I mean but taxes
is crazy right taxes is where I feel
like how much you pay in taxes what is
it I remember
0.13% is it the same yeah 0 point yeah
is it half that oh that's a sale tax oh
my yeah no but like your income tax like
a lot is is it half is it more than La
no no no no no no no no no no no no La
is [__] no it's not like that no no no
it's not like that it's a lot but it's
not so you don't pay as much man La
taxes is different bro it's [__]
crazy we don't even get all the we don't
even get free healthare we got to dodge
[__] fentanyl smoke and homeless
people [__] on the streets it's crazy
man La is a wild [__] place I feel it
for La man everybody's getting robbed
out here and [__] it's crazy it's crazy
man Jesus kind of everywhere right now
everyone should move to Canada no listen
there you can getting robbed too in
Canada don't get it twisted right but
but you know can you defend yourself in
Canada no oh you can't have a gun out
there right no no well how do you feel
about the Trudeau guy a lot of people
don't seem to like
him
oh man everybody has mixed
emotions I mean I I like everybody you
know what I'm saying but it's also it's
politics it's politics I don't know much
about him I just know that a lot of
people I know think he's [__] nobody
everybody has there's people like him
there people don't like him you know
it's almost like you know when I feel
like when Trump was in office there was
people who liked him there's people who
don't like him right well Trump is a
maniac psychopath but also politics boy
politics yeah our president now is a
zombie so it's like pick your poison
right want the orange psychopath or you
want the pick you pick half dead you
know it what it is did you see Dwayne
Johnson they wanted him somebody wanted
him to run for office or some [__] i'
vote for The Rock right now yeah it was
crazy yeah I mean I would too yeah for
sure yeah [__] yeah I'm not I'm not
American but I would I love are you are
you a wrestling fan yeah man what WWE
was my [__] smack you know some of the
greatest wrestlers ever come from
Canada and Edmonton you know I didn't
know that growing up though I'm just all
the actually I met I met I met uh heart
yeah yeah I met his son I was with his
son just but uh the last one of the
shows in Calgary or when I can't
remember it was Calgary Ed yeah they're
from Calgary yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
very dope good people man good Chris
benois was from I know he was called him
the Canadian cripper he's Canadian I
think he was from I can't
remember the Canadian murderer that sad
story dog yeah super sad sad story sad
story man I just kill this whole family
I was young I didn't know about that
story I just watched that story recently
and I learned about it it was very
steroids crazy story man crazy man yeah
very sad sad that's dope I need to go to
Canada and just get some free healthcare
can I go out there for like two months
if I need some major [__] done get the
health no nah you got to you got to you
got to get pregnant dog oh so you got to
you got to be a citizen so yeah you got
to be a citizen yeah figure that out go
up to Vancouver smoke some weed with
Nardo get some
surgery that's where he's from right Nar
yeah yeah yeah have you ever
met met totally other side of the
country I mean yeah but I love Vancouver
but I never met him yet
nor holl at me man what's smells crazy
that's a crazy thing to say I've met him
like five times every time that's
outrageous how you just saying that
about man N I don't know I I've
literally met him four or five times
sweetest guy yeah he's got the worst Bo
I've ever smell in did you tell him like
he's a rip I told him I said you're ripe
aren't
you it's a ripe ass [__] dude right
there man I don't think he has time to
shower he's too busy doing research you
know you savage my boy you you nard is
doing research the whole time you don't
have time to shower that's crazy that
motherfucker's too busy like on the dark
web trying to find out stuff about
people oh man he said hey you got do the
nire interview soon yeah I do man I'm
give you some tips I got I need to come
with my skin skincare routine for these
[__] man I need to need to get it
going get it popping
uh
how much uh are you finished with this
new album uh 20% 30% half I would say
about half a little bit more than that
you working on the road or not yeah I'm
working on the road yeah yeah yeah
always I love working on the road so
inspiration is there anybody who you
have who have come out the last like
five or six years that you would
consider like a newer artist that you
would love to work with that you're just
a fan of um first person that came to
mind Bea so fire man yeah beia when I
when she started popping I was taking
her taking in her music a lot she's so
[__] fire she's super fire and she's
like the coolest chick ever yeah never
met her yet yeah but yeah she's mad cool
man she's from Boston yeah oh Sor east
side but I mean yeah you know have you
been to Boston yeah I love Boston
Boston's A vibe I love Boston they got
good food there yeah just a lot of like
uh you know Dusty white women there I
actually I don't know about that I've
ran into a lot of Latinos there are like
yeah especially there a lot of Puerto
Rican chicks in Lawrence Lawrence
Massachusetts Lawrence
is Right very specific I us to D there
it's either bad bad Latin women or
chicks that sound like Ted the the teddy
bear movie you are something else
dog every every white chick in Boston
sounds like they' [__] smoked for 30
years what you we talking about with
that accent [__] Tom
Brady [__] Tom I want to hear I never
heard of Bost the [__] K let's get in
the Uber baby I would love to hear a
Boston I've never heard of you oh you
will one day yeah you have a groupy and
then as soon as she opens her mouth
she'll become unattractive to you be
like oh [__] she'll be like godamn have
you ever have you ever hit with that
accent
no no not at all couldn't do it nope
nope nope no good good good I feel that
lots of cap Cape Verdian women over
there though lots of what Cape Verdian
women from cap oh really yeah damn
really random super fire random um all
right so look the tour is going down
right now um people uh how many dates
left uh um about what five five or so
all right so go get some tickets uh the
album came out what in July June uh
August August or
July yeah July sport the album new music
right the end of July you're not going
to make everybody wait for new music
like last time no no I I'm working on it
right now yeah L and I got a EP yeah I
got a EP and album so I'm I'm trust me
I'm doubling it up when's EP dropping
first uh I might yeah I'm going to drop
the EP first year um um if not this year
then definitely beginning of next year
all you got a lot of music coming yeah
man lots of music so they're not going
to miss Roy Woods man Roy Woods
appreciate you pulling up brother thank
you for yes sir [__] the Steelers hey
[__] you
man [__]
you most polite [__] you ever such a
Canadian [__] you yo we're wrapping up
an interview man of course we want to
shout out to our family at hardine baby
Harden Las Vegas celebrating their th
birthday this month so happy birthday to
harden uh want to give a shout out to
the whole family over there when you're
in Las Vegas you got to pull up the
Hardin tell them that the bootle head
podcast sends you they're going to take
care of you it is the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis in the country all
Under One Roof you walk in and it's just
a Vibe beautiful Bud tenders amazing
smoke just the illst merch you know what
I'm saying and it's right in Las Vegas
right in Sin City so you land in Vegas
you about to go gamble with your boys
you get in that cab you say take me to
harden they're going to know exactly
where to take you all right shout out to
harden go follow him Harden Las Vegas or
go to the website Hardin Las vegas.com